Merci, au revoir.
Ouf,
T’as une petite tête toi
aujourd’hui.
Bah, comme un lundi.
NON, NON, NON
à la solitude !
C’est ma...
mallette, enculé!
Chacun a son arc,
chaque perso a son arc
dans la saison.
Et dans chaque épisode
souvent en fait,
souvent les secondaires,
souvent Phoebe ou Joey
tu vois qui sont plus là
pour les vannes.
Oui, oui. Très bien.
Messieurs,
vous disposez
très exactement de 5 secondes,
pour sauver la terre.
Ecoute Aristide, je t’aime beaucoup,
c’est pas la question,
on a passé
de très bons moments toi et moi.
Mais ça marchera jamais.
Tu dis ça
parce que je suis noir
ET blanc, c’est ça?
Regardez, c’est un avion!
Non, c’est un oiseau!
Non, c’est …
C’est super bizarre …
Messieurs,
désirez-vous autre chose?
L’addition,
on va prendre l’addition.
Les codes sont 8, 6, 4.
Ah, attendez,
je crois qu’on est sur écoute.
(rires)
Tu penses à ce que je pense?
Ouais.
Pourquoi t’as fait ça?
Bon, je suis désolé,
faut que je file.
Vas y, vas y,
bah à jeudi mec.
Oui.
"Ce n’était pas la première fois,
que Patrick"
"accouchait d’un tabouret un plastique. "
"Un soldat de la garde royale britannique
était venu spécialement de Londres,"
"pour nous jouer la marche turque
en slip"
"et des cerfs tiraient des lasers
avec leurs sexes respectifs."
Bref, la vie suivait son cours.
(Cri étrange)